lorence Harding in one word,
I would pick the
word determined.
She was determined to propel
her husband's career along.
She was determined to be
an advocate for women.
She was determined to
protect her husband's legacy.
She was fierce in that way.
(upbeat music)
People said had Warren
Harding not met Florence,
he would have
remained a small-town
newspaper editor his whole life.
- When she married
Warren Harding,
who was the editor
of The Marion Star,
she basically took over.
He had actually had
a nervous breakdown,
and Florence stepped up,
and ran the newspaper.
She was an extremely
savvy businesswoman.
- Florence Harding saw in Warren
the ability for him to go
very, very far in politics,
and she pushed him to be
involved in local politics,
state politics, and
to move up the ladder.
- She really pushed Warren
Harding into the Presidency.
And after he was inaugurated,
she turned to him and said,
I got you the Presidency,
now what are you
going to do with it?
- Florence Harding was
different from the First Ladies
who came before her.
She was the first First Lady
to vote for her husband,
because she's the
first First Lady
after women were
granted suffrage.
And she was certainly
the first First Lady
to state openly and often
that she was not just
pro-suffrage, but a feminist.
She did not wear a wedding ring.
She used her maiden
name on purpose,
as other First Ladies
would after her.
- She was a very strong
activist in women's rights.
Little things at
that particular time.
For instance, she
invited divorced women
into various social events,
which broke an unwritten rule.
She invited scientist Madame
Curie to the White House
to promote education for women.
- She made sure
that women's rights
stayed on the national agenda.
When Mrs. Harding
became First Lady,
one of the things
she wanted to do
was to open the White House
again to all Americans.
Because of Wilson's health
and because of World War I,
the White House had become
closed to Americans.
- Often times she
would come downstairs,
the public were very
excited when they walk in
thinking they were
going to see a docent,
and the First Lady would walk
over and show them the house.
The public loved her
because she was so gracious,
and warm and entertaining.
- Like many First Ladies,
Florence Harding believed
that she could read people
better than her husband.
- She was very opinionated
about his Cabinet.
It was very important
to her that her husband
surround himself with
the right people.
Well, she also surrounded
Warren Harding with men
that he unfortunately
could not control.
It wasn't Warren Harding
himself that was corrupt,
it was his administration,
and that infuriated Florence.
- He died virtually alone in
a hotel room in California
and when she refused an autopsy,
she kicked off all
sorts of suspicions
that somehow she had been
complicit in his death,
which historians believe
is not at all true.
After his death, there were
scandals rising to the surface.
Mrs. Harding worked
very hard to make sure
that his legacy
was a positive one.
It did not work.
We don't remember Harding
among our top Presidents.